les républicains après avoir gagné
toutes les élections territoriales sont
prêts incarner l'alternance à ce
gouvernement nous avons d'abord établi
notre projet nous aurons notre candidat
le 4 le 4 décembre prochain à l'occasion
de notre congrès il faut effectivement
une alternance lé quinquennat qui vient
de se passer est un quinquennat d'échec
un échec sur toute la ligne d'abord sur
le plan économique parlons avant que
vides avant que vides ce sont des
dépenses publiques qui explose plus vite
d'ailleurs que sous françois hollande
c'est dire si françois hollande n'était
pas une référence c'est un gouvernement
qui est totalement incapable de porter
une réforme de structure le premier
gouvernement depuis 20 ans à être
incapable de mettre en place une réforme
des retraites c'est l'insécurité qui se
développe dans chaque ville dans les
quartiers partout et puis c'est une
immigration qui est totalement hors
contrôle comme on ne l'a jamais été oui
nous sommes différents nous sommes la
droite vous êtes le en même temps nous
sommes la france des territoires vous
êtes la force des déracinés vous êtes
aussi vous êtes aussi responsable de
l'échec du en même temps cette politique
dès 2000 mesures sur l'insécurité la
délinquance et l'islamisme alors
monsieur le premier ministre votre
mission c'est de gouverner la france pas
de dynamiter la droite sans d'ailleurs y
parvenir ne devons pas céder à la
fatalité ou au fatalisme la lutte contre
le terrorisme islamiste appelle bien sûr
un arsenal sécuritaire judiciaire il
appelle surtout qu'on applique la loi
telle que nous l'avons déjà
mais l'exigent cette lutte aussi de ne
rien céder de ne rien céder sur nos
valeurs sur ce que nous sommes de
reconquérir tous les territoires perdus
de notre république où qu'ils soient au
sens propre comme au sens figuré hâtif
la colère aujourd'hui je ne la retient
dre pas c'est la colère de ces milliers
de femmes en danger qui vous entends
dire blanc et vous vois faire noir qui
voit une secrétaire d'état encore
absente aujourd'hui bada c sur les
plateaux de télévision alors que
l'essentiel n'est jamais fait plutôt que
les artifices de la communique de
communication au front à la génération
qui vient une europe enfin réveillé qui
puise entier à nos pays les moyens de
maîtriser leur destin monsieur le
premier ministre
ce ministre qui pour les uns nous disent
de sortir que nous avons rien à faire
dans l'hémicycle et pour les autres nous
explique qu'il faut qu'on leur soumettre
les questions c'est inacceptable c'est
le gouvernement qui est responsable
devant parlement veut s'il ministre vous
n'êtes vous êtes ici responsable devant
nous et c'est nous qui vous interrogeons
et nous attendre si monsieur tavernost
le français cinquième langue la plus
parlée au monde et fragilisé en france
alors qu'elle le français est admiré est
célébrée partout dans le monde quel
paradoxe défendent opposé des jeunes aux
plus âgés le nord au sud de l'est à
l'ouest et maintenant hélas les origines
il ne peut y avoir qu'une seule
communauté nationale et le singulier
pour moi est essentiel car il se
conjugue avec la république et les
valeurs qui sont les lots pour toutes
ces raisons aujourd'hui que les
républicains doivent incarner cette
alternance à la fois en incarnant
l'autorité l'ordre le respect des règles
pour tous et puis également une gestion
des finances publiques comme l'ont fait
tous nos pays voisins au delà de
l'autorité du droit il y a une valeur
cardinale c'est la valeur travail la
valeur travail ça veut dire que c'est le
travail qui doit être l'élément
déterminant du revenu ça n'est pas
l'assistanat rejoignez-nous aux
républicains aux républicains nous avons
montré que nous avions cette capacité à
gérer les collectivités les français
nous ont fait confiance à toutes les
élections territoriales nous avons
largement gagné les municipales les
départementales les régionales c'est
pour ça que pour gagner la france pour
gagner l'élection présidentielle
nous avons besoin de vous venez avec
nous chez les républicains